all right babe I'm going out cool
me and the girls got it
we probably get up tonight do you
I don't know what time we coming back
I'll be sleep either way it's fine
where you going
I don't even know yet
[Music]
who going with you whoever come I guess
I don't know
what y'all gonna do I'm trying to figure
it out now I don't know what we're doing
y'all go eat I hope so I'm hungry I
haven't eaten
what time you getting back whatever time
we done what the is going on here
it's not the funniest bit it's just that
there's a mismatch between the voice and
the people it's really basic they always
say the way to make a joke funnier is to
explain it and it's the incongruity
that's and I guess men and women are
different that's true